[Music]
what is up reject nation we are going to
watch today
from new rock stars black widow movie
easter eggs and breakdown this is a
movie that we've had an interesting
experience with
put up our movie reaction for it i see
some people who are
showing up thinking that we hate the
movie when we never said that and then
there are some people who are
showing up who don't like the movie but
are seeing the thumbnail of that video
thinking that we love it so much that
i'm going to dislike it
because you shills love everything when
really
really it's okay this is all right we
have good stuff definite criticisms our
own subjective opinions but as reflected
in the comments of the movie reaction
and as what we said
a couple weeks ago we're hoping most
people walk out of it liking it seems
like for the most part marvel fans are
enthused and here's the thing though
what i've noticed is and this is what
i'm kind of hoping for
from this reaction today sometimes we
might just find something
okay but then a new rockstars video this
has happened before
where this learning a little bit more in
depth can make us appreciate the movie
that much more and i'm kind of hoping
that's what eric delivers on again
for us but we'll see we'll just have to
be honest whether or not it does
anything to
enhance our appreciation let's see
what's in store
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel
studios black widow
which finally tells the story of the
most secretive avenger and the blood on
her ledger
really is the first mcu film to release
after a two-year gap it's just welcome
relief to appreciate all the interesting
filmmaking details the mcu easter eggs
and other hidden gems that appear all
over this film
let's hear it and let's dive into the
past or the
past and before you go be sure to head
over to new rockstarsmerch.com
for our black widow inspired latest
obsession shirt i kind of play on the
classic hourglass logo
super limited supply we got another
black widow shirt design you might like
as well as some loki designs like the
gator loki polo shirt and the loki out
of time tea that i'm wearing
get it all at new rockstars merch i own
a copy we open in ohio 1995 where
natasha romanov age 11 played by ever
anderson daughter of milo jovovich spent
her youth with a family of russian spies
now these include
elena bilova florence pew but here
violet mcgraw black widow's longtime
rival in the comics
alexi shostakov aka the red guardian
david harbor a soviet counterpart to
captain america
and molina vostakov rachel weiss aka the
iron maiden from the comics but from
this dysfunctional family unit we get
this film central thematic conflict
forgiving your family because the main
events of black widow are set right
after captain america's civil war in
2016
two years before the avengers would
reunite infinity war but in this interim
period with her avengers family and this
kind of divorce
natasha romanov must both forgive and
seek forgiveness from her past family so
that she can learn to heal
the family that she chose similar to the
premise of the americans on fx
russian spy families are actually a real
world thing in 2010 the fbi arrested 10
russian
illegals including four couples who
who'd all been living undercover in
america for years
with a tv report from w-h-i-h that's
marvel's in universe news service about
natasha's family being outed
evoking those reports that we saw in
2010 i was actually
not fully aware of all that historical
significance that they were playing on i
thought it was just like a cool
fictional thing that seated movies and
shows off for such a long time i had no
idea it was happening as recently as
2010. and that is true about the theme
forgiving family i think that's a
necessary thing because i think
80 percent a little bit more than 80
percent of
people think that their family is
dysfunctional so
i think that was the stat i heard like
10 years ago so maybe it's caught up
weirdly that there's a very universal
theme
forgive your your your fake family
thrust upon you assembled by a spy's
family but the year 1995 is an eventful
one in mcu history
as shield was stretched thin dealing
with the skrulls and the cree and the
return of carol danvers
the events of captain marvel but also
elsewhere in the universe gamora was
taken from her native people and turned
into a deadly weapon by thanos parallel
to the girl
soldier future awaiting these two well
clearly 1995 was a significant year
for uh the women in the mcu absolutely i
want a whole
90s universe of just the female
characters
young natasha has blue hair covering up
her red roots all ready for telling a
life of hair alteration
and masking her red the sisters exchange
this whistle
which they echo to say goodbye at the
end of the film
in the opening oh i did not pick up on
that oh yeah i'm down
and i bet you're gonna fall out first
and later when natasha finds the elaine
on the ground
elena says we're both upside down hey
all right okay all right i gotta give
credit to that that's something that
this that flew over this guy's head
entirely
i did not uh flash back to the beginning
of the movie and clearly they are
directly making a bookend yeah yeah
because
she is rejecting them as her real family
and in that moment she is accepting no
you are my sister this mirror is the
moment of family bonding
that's good it's good good good point
good writing and visual star talent
after stealing a secret government disc
they have to flee
and they play elena's favorite song don
mclean's american pie
a song about the 1959 plane crash that
killed early rock and roll stars buddy
holly richie valens and the big bopper
a song that many interpret as a kind of
allegory for american pop culture
throughout the 50s and 60s with all
these crazy specific references that don
mclean has cryptically never
acknowledged what they actually mean but
generally it is about american
disillusionment of that era but
interestingly elena just likes a song
for its simple catchy melody
not really realizing the darker truth of
the lyrics me too
most people probably without really
understanding the darkness of what's
going on notice how the song plays over
some departing images of americana
including a football game recalling the
lyrics of the fourth verse of american
pie about a football game halftime
marching band refusing to leave the
field which some say could have really
been about the beatles rock takeover
with sergeant pepper and in the shot you
can see the marching band on the far
end of the field there when they get to
the plane alexi clears away by showing
some surprising super strength
that's a good moment notice how the
trailer flips with just a solid thud
no bounce just a subtle animation effect
showing how heavy this thing is
now they're pursued by shield suvs not
those of the fbi or even the local pd
indicating that they're not being chased
because they're russian spies but
because they interfered with a shield
operation which we learn more about when
they arrive in cuba and meet with
general drakov
and the north institute
yes the north institute is from a 2004
run of black widow comics the institute
worked on behalf of the gynecon
corporation
i know it's called
after they purchased the russian biotech
from the red room's successor but in
this film it's a similar program but run
by
shields which was secretly run by hydra
at the time in conjunction with their
winter soldier program to produce a
cellular map
of the inner brain for chemically
induced mind control
but dracov is a familiar name in the mcu
first mentioned by
loki all the way back in the first
avengers film i got red in my ledger
i'd like to wipe it out can you
can you wipe out that much red
draco's daughter and yes we will meet
drakov's daughter very soon but these
opening titles are scored by nirvana's
smells like teen spirit but covered by
think
up anger featuring malia j now this song
was written by kurt cobain as an
anarchic anthem for disaffected gen xers
but now through this female voice it's
used to convey these girls being
converted into mindless assets for the
interests of the powerful yeah it's
funny like that
cover i've seen some people really love
the use of that cover and i've seen some
people
really not like it at all but the
justification that he is giving here say
that what the director is intending to
convey at least i don't know if that's
like a quote or if that's just something
eric's interpreting
yeah if that is the intention because i
like the montage a lot and i didn't know
how i really felt about the choice of
song
yeah yeah because i have such a
gargantuan song
yeah and i have such an association with
like growing up listening to it all the
time and then like the original meaning
of it to hear it kind of flip with just
a
simple change of having it be a female
vocalist and then the imagery of what
it's overlapping i can see
how that could be the case which would
make me like that more well yeah and i
could also see how
natasha at the age we first meet her
during the 90s like
might have been listening to smells like
teen spirit you know she's got like the
punked out hair and stuff like that too
like i feel like you could draw
multiple connecting lines that aren't
that far-fetched to actually having
significance of the song
notice how natasha breaks away to give
you elena something folded this was the
photo booth strip that she took from the
car which elena later uses in the movie
to mark her message for natasha the
montage has a close-up of drakov's ring
which
later is the key that natasha uses to
unlock and download all the red room
data the montage shows footage of them
staging home videos of christmas and
other holidays as natasha reveals later
that all the photos in their albums were
shot on a single day with different
backdrops to make them look like a
convincingly american family we see a
close-up of a red hair bow
rotating to become the hourglass shape
of the black widow logo
now on a human target similar to the
ones natasha remembered shooting at in
her red room flashbacks in age of ultron
but we're actually people we see imagery
of the north institute file
and pigs a clue for how melina will use
the north institute data to test mind
control on pigs first but then later on
humans that are being used as
metaphorical pigs for the slaughter and
then all these crazy photos of drakov
photoshopped in the photos with various
world leaders including jimmy carter
bill clinton boris yeltsin condoleezza
rice and vladimir putin yeah so much for
this guy staying in the shadows
21 years later in 2016 right after civil
war when she's on the run william hurt
returns to thaddeus ross and says tasha
romanov is in violation of the sokovia
accords
she assaulted the king of wakanda make
an example out of her
yes referring to the superhero
registration law that captain america
refused to sign and natasha despite
initially agreeing with tony stark
swung over to team cap by attacking
black panther to allow cap and bucky to
escape
and ross tells her we got barton we got
wilson another guy the incredible
shrinking convict
referring to the members of team cap who
at this point were still imprisoned on
the raft
including hawkeye and falcon and the
incredible shrinking convict is ant-man
scott lang and i love how he uses the
hulk's incredible moniker for that
natasha brings up ross's triple bypass
surgery that he used to explain his
absence at the start of civil war but
she slips on by actually being on a
ferry to norway girl i'll get
you black widow in morocco adult elaine
beloveda leads a team
targeting an older widow roxanna who
sprays the elena with the antidote to
the widow's chemical subjugation i like
how during their knife fight yelena
drops the knife from one hand to the
other i love that move natasha actually
later uses it while fighting taskmaster
just showing some of their parallel
training so it's like little things like
that that i appreciate the most with the
visual story details i didn't pick up on
that that both
natasha and her did that and it's cool
that for the fight choreography they
would give them
similar fighting styles considering
where they both trained and that knife
like one thing that i really feel like
with the mcu when it comes to their hand
to hand is the use of knives bucky
now in this movie the daggers with loki
like their use of knives used to be the
best thing they have going with
signature handheld combat moves so yeah
absolutely because you could do cool
memorable stuff like that
we first meet taskmaster as they watched
footage from the civil war airport
battle of hawkeye fighting black panther
that was actually updated from the
trailer version of the shot that showed
you a
ride of natasha and iron man so in the
comics taskmaster is tony masters a
mercenary an assassin with photographic
reflexes that mirror the combat style of
any combatant but this film changes the
character too
as we learn in the third act of the film
antonia drakov's daughter with all of
her mirrored fighting not being an
innate physical skill but instead based
on some fighting analysis algorithm in
her heads-up display in her helmet and
the chip that's in the back of her head
so she's a bit more uh terminatory now
but i'll say this is similar to the
upgrade in iron man's mark 46
armor that he used to also predict cap's
fighting combat style in civil war in a
safe house natasha
a meadows of local drivers licenses
fanny longbottom
yeah later on in the post-credits scene
elena names her dog fanny
and then this exchange i didn't pick up
on that either
yes natasha is using the hungarian
pronunciation calling back her exchange
with hawkeye in avengers
just like buddhism all over again you
and i remember budapest very differently
hawkeye wasn't involved in budapest
story here right
no not here i'm not missing anything am
i
i thought with like the key flashback it
would be something with both her
and hawkeye the buddha patch memory is
the story of when she killed draco or
she
thought she killed drakov and drakov's
daughter yeah because she's a crappy
assassin and couldn't take down
a kid and a an overweight man
[Laughter]
those are usually your practice targets
damn nice just a joke guys
[Music]
natasha looks at some blonde hair dye
setting up how she will change her hair
by the end of this film to set up her
look in avengers infinity war and she
watches the double 07 roger moore film
moonraker
with some surprisingly similar plot
points as black widow
including a skydive parachute sequence
that people definitely should not have
survived and a hidden base floating in
secret above earth
oh yeah moonraker love
i know it's like comic book movies
especially like logan with shane
they'll do that thing where like oh
let's just let the audience really
clue them in on what it is we're
referencing or homogeneous yeah instead
you know we'll have to actually appear
in the film for the
wise person who's really looking for it
yeah i should have remembered moonraker
the best bomb
everyone loves moonraker but taskmaster
attacks natasha using the shield with a
discus hurl that she likely got from
watching footage of captain america and
i love this detail when natasha crawls
out of her vehicle looking for
taskmaster notice how the vehicle
suddenly stops
teetering even though without nat
nothing would be weighing down that side
of the vehicle telling us that it was
taskmaster who had landed on
with her classic scissors maneuver but
taskmaster uses it right back on her
now within taskmaster's heads up display
on the right are the words evaluating
defensive measures with on the left
a predict percentage and a threat
percentage and then various
pressure points on her body with
percentages maybe to show how effective
that region would be or how likely
natasha is to use it and again yes this
is very similar to stark's mark 46 text
so much so that i'm wondering if a
version or an early prototype of it
could have been stolen from stark's
research they do simultaneous flip jumps
to their feet something that natasha
remembers as a move she later uses in
combination with the downward punch
to release the antidote and then in the
second scan taskmaster's display shows
two numbers per arm the top of which may
correspond to the likelihood she'll
strike with that side the bottom maybe
meaning how much of a threat that strike
would be and then the directive has
changed to
redirect to primary target meaning that
all of this is being viewed remotely by
dracop giving her commands
yeah i like those details i love those
details
i love them you get the immediate idea
of taskmasters doing some scanning on
her little things
like that i wish we kind of honed in on
a little bit more in the movie to really
let you
live within because i think a common
consensus while some people really did
like taskmaster ultimately i feel like
even for a lot of people who ultimately
enjoyed this film it seems to be they
kind of wanted a little bit more
taskmaster
being like taskmaster getting a clear
sense of how
like the specifics of taskmaster work
would have been really cool
tad bit more that i would have
appreciated cause those are details that
you want to ring true anyway like you
want to have those like little readouts
and numbers you know be able to
correlate maybe
in a video like this to something real
and so i feel like yeah as long as they
took the time to theorize how all this
could work yeah it could have definitely
bolstered the character to at least
have had that be apparent in the film
because in this
format it's you know it's little details
that you'll blink and miss
yeah but knowing it makes it more
suspenseful i think absolutely and
that's why i wish we could really
relationship had some kind of clue yeah
a deliberate clue natasha lasso's
taskmaster to the overhead beam but
taskmaster slashes it and swings into
this acrobatic flip
maybe a move that she got from watching
videos of spider-man that we know are on
youtube at this point and knocks natasha
off the ledge but with her the vials so
natasha takes these to budapest where
she spars with yelena and then after the
fight she asks
what bullet does that
my bullets arrows another reminder
natasha and hawkeyes passed in budapest
and perhaps this was some scuffle after
their attempt to kill dracob which
natasha reveals was the final step
in her defection to shields
it would have been a perfect caveat but
natasha says they aren't talking just
one example of how the civil war really
just left the world a less
safe place they're chased by other
widows one tragically breaks her leg so
drakov decides to terminate her remotely
from his tablet
yikes taskmaster chases them in a
freaking tank plowing through the cars
on the street as they are fleeing on a
motorcycle and with taskmaster's
terminator essence it's just hard not to
see this as an homage to the chase
natasha and elena hide from taskmaster
in a ceiling bent
martin and i spent two days hiding out
up here the doodles include a hawkeye
arrow some games of tic-tac-toe in a
game of hangman it's hard to make out
what the word was supposed to be
but based on the letters and the wrong
letters already chosen i'm gonna guess
butterfly now flashback shows that
budapest mission with natasha tracking
drakov's daughter
[Music]
yeah that sound effect of antonia
stepping out of the car is a modulated
version of the sound taskmaster made
earlier
really let's hear it again just a little
clue telling us that they are the same
person elena explains that the reason
that greycover stayed off of natasha's
radar or never tried to kill her was to
stay hidden from the big avengers
wait what are the big ones well i doubt
the god from space has to take an
ibuprofen after a fight
of course referencing thor though thor
was off world during civil war elena
mocks natasha's landing pose
with the hair flip back it's a fighting
pose you're a total poser not a poser
one of my favorite running jokes of the
movie but also an example of how to
elena and natasha's
family of the avengers seems like a joke
a way of hitting back at her for natasha
saying elena thinking her
ohio family was so great that being a
joke later they talk about their parents
did you ever look for your parents
they're real ones
my mom abandoned me in the straight like
garbage
an endgame natasha would be shaken to
hear red skull call her
daughter of ivan meaning she has some
father out there named ivan but back in
infinity war he also called gamora
daughter of thanos when he was not her
biological father just a very hands-on
paternal figure
so really this leaves this ivan guy uh
mcu mystery
it's canon red skull is a freaking idiot
dude red skull
do your homework bro what are you doing
on vermeer all day
you got nothing else better yeah just no
people
no remember the parents of people who
might show up one day you got a few
things to say to people and one of them
is their dad it's not that hard
[Laughter]
or maybe red skull was like she doesn't
know who her
father is i could say whatever name i
want
i can screw this her
okay who was involved in that mission
elena said she invented histories for
them all my sister moved out west
is that right you're a science teacher
your husband
he renovates houses i like to think of
this hypothetical life as natasha marian
bruce banner who
does in a way renovate houses elena
mentions wanting a daughter
which she doesn't get in the
post-credits scene on the drive delena
says
see my vest it has a lot of pockets
but i use them all the time i've never
had control over my own life before and
now i do
so when she gives this vest to natasha
and nat shows up wearing this same vest
in infinity war it's not just about the
pockets folks it is a symbol of she and
her sister having more control over
their lives and we catch up with alexi
in prison
[Music]
yeah the other prisoner is right to
point out if this was 1983 or 84 steve
rogers was still frozen in ice
and assuming alexie had been in prison
for longer than five years it's
impossible for the two to have ever met
or capped to have any idea who he is and
alexi goes on with this story
anyway this shield you know that he
carries with him like
like a precious baby blanket you know i
i use it to my advantage i take it i
push him out the window
what do you think about it alexi does
get a kind of victory moment this way in
the final sequence using the shield to
his advantage to smash a soldier through
the window of the jet 3c films chris
from 3c films he brought up a great
point later on
when alexi is reunited with nat and
elena he's saying like did the captain
america ever talk about me and
back about our time like he's asking it
like sincerely yeah
like either this guy's crazy and really
believes he fought captain america
or he fought like an isaiah bradley or
yeah like somebody else who would winter
soldier opposing his cap and what
i'm like why would he do that maybe it's
a multiverse thing until we can chalk
everything
up here that's what that's what we can
do now he got pruned from this timeline
but somehow alexia remembers or maybe it
was the cat that went back to end game
and then they [ __ ] and then they
fought i think chris gave the theater
his prison tattoos are awesome including
a russian imperial eagle on his chest
and carl
and marks across his knuckles natasha
and elena cinema red guardian action
figure
yeah it sounds like david harper
actually recorded the russian
catchphrase for the toy and i love that
natasha and elena assumed he would be
wistful enough to pull that string so
that he would find the earpiece in the
head
on their tablet this prison is called
seventh circle prison which is the name
of a run of the punisher daredevil
comics but
also the circle in hell and dante's
inferno for souls that have committed
acts of violence
alexi is strong enough to break glass
and kick down the doors but
not to climb the second level perhaps
justifying why he was unable to escape
in the past natasha does her post
landing elena blows the tower which
triggers an avalanche and alexis
springboard's office shield to make it
up finally similar to that moment in the
avengers when natasha springboarded from
cap shield to hop up to some chitari and
then after lifting him out yolanda hits
alexi for abandoning them and he asks if
it's her time of the month to which they
respond
i don't have a uterus yeah that's what
happens when the red room gives you an
involuntary hysterectomy yes a much more
vivid description of what natasha
described in age of ultron to bruce
banner
they have a graduation ceremony they
sterilize you
it's efficient one less thing to worry
about i've heard that scene kind of
debated about in terms of handling it
there are some people who
actually i i people have private
conversations with who
you might have seen on this platform of
youtube before really don't like that
scene
and think that it undercuts the weight
like how
uh nat had that whole speech in age of
ultron and also it's just a real life
thing
to me that's actually a moment where i'm
like yeah it's awkward
however it's coming from elena and elena
does a lot of sarcastic suppression so
with her delivery and her
the choice of how she chooses it and
when to say it intentionally to
kind of unsettle alexi well it made
sense to me like i wasn't there going oh
bad choice marvel why are you trying to
make this funny you know well to me it
read like
oh you you're grossed out by this like
this is just our lives this is what you
put us through this is you know
like treated like it's normal and so
like yeah i like i would never uh try to
argue anybody out of if they don't like
the way the moment was handled but i do
feel like coming from the character i
could see how
it rings true in that sense that's what
i mean like strictly coming from elena's
mouth
yes and why yeah absolutely and they're
also in the middle of a mission you know
you can't get as
sort of like worked up as you can in an
intimate scene with that's fair so they
find molina on her pig farm where she's
using mind control tech to
guide these pigs through a maze like lab
rats i just feel so bad for these pigs
especially that alexi one the one she
nearly
suffocates of course not to mention the
human test subjects whom she never
really seems to feel that bad about
torturing
we stole the key to unlocking free will
the world functions on a higher level
when it is controlled
which leads to an argument over whether
they were true family at any point
our family was never real so there's
nothing to hold on to
please don't say that it was real
it was real to me you are my mother you
were my real mother
but afterwards melina and natasha end up
coming together over natasha learning
that her biological mother continued to
look for her and then was killed off by
draco
i just feel like melina switch comes a
bit too quickly as if she might have had
another agenda here like she could have
revealed this to natasha in order to
gain her trust but really to further
incentivize natasha to kill dracov in
order to remove him from the widow
program and allow melina to step in and
take over the operation like i just have
a lot of questions about her plan the
way she has only one earpiece set which
is kind of a weird detail almost like
melina wanted all the communication of
this plan to go through her
and this plan was to offer to help land
the red room right into ross's lap even
though that could end up with her behind
bars
and she does this by sneaking into the
engine control room
of a base that she designed and
therefore would know that dracop would
be watching her so that she would have
to
oopsie daisy goes with dania the engine
to crash the whole thing that would
conveniently destroy all evidence of her
role in this chemically subjugating
women program
i am just saying things lucked out
pretty great for the iron maiden
let's keep an eye on that one oh
insurance
that's a rich nugget right there so
sometimes mr voss is
theorizing out of a little but he had a
lot to back up that theory that there's
really more than meets the eye here when
it comes to iron maiden
and i'm thinking back to the experience
watching the movie now and like the
pivot at which she decides to like fully
help out and become a member of the team
and i'm like did it feel a little bit
sort of funky right after she just
tortured that pig and didn't seem to
care
yeah yeah like i could see it being some
kind of greater long game
i mean she out of anyone seems to be
like at least the way she was coming
across
seemed to have been the most cold toward
the whole idea of family it's a mission
i'm a scientist
i'm an agent i'm just doing what i had
she seemed like the most
collected about it or it was just you
know
the movie moved the way it was because
it needed to
in order to get the plot going yeah yeah
that could be it too
great is that but back while they're
talking elena snaps at alexi
the only thing you care about are your
stupid glory days is the crimson dynamo
and no one wants to hear about it
it's the red guardian crimson dynamo was
another russian marvel villain for whom
in iron man 2 they took the name
anton vanko ivan vanko's father and
ivan's fake id bore the name boris
turganev who was the second crimson
dynamo in the comics drakov's forces
arrive and elena finds natasha or who
she thinks is natasha but in that closet
the
masks are no longer hanging and the red
and brunette wigs aren't taken away
just a clue that natasha and molina must
have swapped and they go to the red rose
kind of a weird thing to say but
remember natasha is a big fan of double
07 a genre where the villains tend to
declare their plans loud
and so by doing this natasha gives alexi
details that he otherwise might not have
had which might be why taskmaster
immediately re-sedates him so natasha
disguised as melina meets with dracov
who gets right up in her face right away
it's
yeah notice he inhales through his nose
briefly and then shortly after he cuts
her off and forces her to sit while
gripping her head
yeah he may have caught from this moment
or even from her scent that this is not
the real molina and then just plays
along and then as draco boxes her in
saying natasha is a traitor the light
from outside dims on his face and then
the jig is up
when you look into the eyes of a child
you have raced
no mask in the world can hide
natasha previously used a similar mask
in captain america the winter soldier
and more recently sharon carter used one
of these in the falcon and the winter
soldier
in drakov's office hangs a portrait of
rasputin this was the mystic healer and
adviser to the final russian royal
family of tsar nicholas ii reflecting
how drakov might see himself as the man
with the magic touch running the empire
from the shadows but really an empire
that is about to topple due to a violent
revolution i just want to say some
i thought ray winstone was very
effective
a lot of people don't care for his
character was the character underwritten
sure but i still thought ray winstone
brought his a game to that role
that whole taunting scene towards the
tasha which i'm sure we might go over a
little bit he was
excellent yeah he was like grew to hate
the sadistic
mad mind that he is yeah just in that
moment like i don't know if i hated him
but i was like oh
i found him very repulsive in the right
ways yes absolutely
yeah when drakov tells antonia to reveal
herself she does so by hitting a
specific button on her buzz lightyear
panel something natasha notices and then
later uses in the final blows of the
fight on the ground to pop open her
helmet so that she can spray her dracoff
reveals he has been making widow agents
out of girls all over the world
it's kind of impossible to count all
them on the screen but by going by the
little red square since we know each
other
looks like about 48 rows down and at
least three times that wide
so around seven thousand widows or more
insanely huge army of assassins but
notice how this map
shows no widows illuminated in the
wakanda region now this is still right
after civil war wakanda has not
yet revealed itself as a major world
power people just think it's a small
poor farming country but really drakov's
talk about toppling world empires really
would not have upset the global status
quo
that much if wakanda remains standing
and once drakov shows his cards by
saying he runs it all from that control
pad
natasha responds thank you for your
cooperation a callback to avengers when
she tricked loki into revealing his plan
thank you for your cooperation so
natasha
severs her olfactory nerve so that she
can attack dracob and you can see the
moment she snatches his ring when she
places her hand on his on the control
pad goes right over the ring and as he
falls back
no ring drakov's glasses fall off as she
hits him but when the widows save him he
puts them back on signaling how he's
back in control
but setting up when he dies his glasses
fly off
after elena blows his getaway jets
engine meanwhile taskmaster's fighting
alexis showing off
zero premium claws like black panther
and kick flips the shield just like
cap's big move
also notice task master shows that she's
been watching footage of the winter
soldier as well because she does bucky's
signature night flip natasha fights
no way says the red light from drakov's
world map beams the faces of the other
girls onto their own faces
just showing how all these women are
connected fighting for the fates of all
the women around the globe
elena hits them all with an antidote
grenade and as natasha downloads the
data about the other widows
their faces flicker past creating this
kind of michael jackson black or white
music video effect oh they all merge
into one just another display of how all
their forced servitude connects them in
a way when natasha frees taskmaster from
the cell taskmaster's heads-up display
and the helmet flickers
a little sign to natasha that the
prediction algorithm is glitching and
she might have a chance to break through
to her
the base explodes and crashes late into
this insane
skydive battle and to stop her sister
from falling
first echoing the first scene natasha
dives after her with a parachute and
then miraculously makes it to the ground
safely enough natasha gets a scissor
kick that antonia is unable to
reciprocate so natasha can open her
helmet and punch the vial
in the aftermath of all this the family
makes their piece if it can work out
with the four of us
you know there may be some hope for the
avengers yes this movie's way of linking
the forgiving family theme with
natasha's coming conflicts alongside the
avengers which natasha echoes again in
the final scene it's funny my whole life
i didn't think i had any family
turns out i got two so one of them is a
bit of a mess right now can i go
break a few of them out of prison see if
i can't help patch things up
with her short blonde hair and yelena's
vest she is ready for when we would
chronologically see her next in infinity
war but wait a minute
what happened i've talked to paul from
heavy spoilers about this quite a bit
what happens she's waiting right she's
waiting at the pile of rubble
and then ross is showing up yeah there's
little voice coming and she's looking at
them
what happened like did ross let her go
but why would ross let her go ross gets
there and she throws all the smoke bombs
down and disappears
did she see them coming and stuff how
she escaped from it they don't explain
what
like i could believe a scenario where
black widow managed to escape from them
but that
seems like something she seems like very
much against her in this
particular situation too yeah and it
certainly seems as though at
what point it is in the action that
she's ready to kind of stand and face
him or something i don't know
the visual language suggests there is a
missing beat there especially because
the next day's like
i'm going to go to that prison that ra
where ross is in charge of yeah i'm
going to bring people out of there you
know
yeah that scene is about her thinking
about talking to ross but then
ultimately deciding on a better plan now
timeline wise this would set all the
2016 events
of black widow just in a few days during
the epilogue civil war linking back up
with cap
as he broke the others out of the raft
at the very end of that film and then
still leaving it a big mystery what they
were all doing for two years on the run
after this and as she takes off in the
quinjet the music
is alan silvestri's avengers theme
[Music]
leaving us with the shot of the
fireflies in the trees just like in the
opening scene but now visually linking
with the gliac
luminescence each glow representing one
of the forgotten lives that these
sisters have now
put on a path to liberation now i broke
down the post-credits scene in a whole
other video go check that out but that
is everything i noticed in black widow
more videos will be coming out on this
channel about this movie soon so be sure
to subscribe to new rockstars follow me
at eavos follow new rockstars thanks for
watching those vidania douchebags
where's the red screen crafting where's
the end screen do you appreciate
the movie more i do no i sincerely i do
i do too
i think like the overwhelming amount of
opinions thrown my way about my opinions
uh have have a little bit overwhelmed me
yeah
and taking it the wind out of me but i
do appreciate it more
like clearly there's some great visual
attention to detail and many moments
that completely flew over my head i
definitely respect it a lot more
do you yeah i don't know seriously i
think it had probably the same effect
on both of us i definitely came out with
a wider appreciation of yeah the
crafting and what you can tell the
intent was
from these little details that we get
and stuff like that yeah it kind of
touched upon
a lot of things that i at least had a
gripe about or something and at least
expanded upon them in a way where i was
like oh yeah there's something to
appreciate there beyond
what my original takeaway was well guys
hope you're doing well
leave your thoughts down below where do
you think do who
which d who do you want to spit off of
or some stupid shitty question
that i i direct towards you to say
whatever you want
uh subscribe click that bell hit that
like button if you care to hey let's do
a
sarah campbell if there's anyone who's a
kick-ass lady at this
channel i think it's you and that's
about the only
kind of connective movie tissue i'm not
gonna pitch you with some
international spy cause you are good
enough as you are
you are a person who seems to have a
wonderful attitude and lust for life i
just appreciate your presence here and
everything that you bring
in our brief but meaningful interactions
your support means a lot and uh
yeah i hope you're doing well if you saw
this movie did you like it let us know
should we have been easier on the movie
should we have been harder on the movie
should we have been
more middle road about the movie let us
know because it's all about pandering
and so i want to know what you
specifically want sarah
that's who we're going to do the next
marvel review for so
get those notes in
that's good thank you sir
[Music]
you